welcome back everyone after lunch uh
we'll go for an hour two to three then
we'll have a coffee break again um for a
half hour or something like that i can't
remember whatever the program says and
then we've got another hour later and
then a reception this evening okay so uh
hope you hang around
over to you again spencer i'm on the for
those of you on zoom i'm on the zoom
call again and i should be able to
monitor questions
okay
um
so we'll pick up where we left off which
well
where we left off was we had just shown
that uh
two graphs generate the same or have the
same these separations if and only if
they have the same skeleton and
immoralities
and now we're going to start by
establishing the connection between d
separation and conditional independence
that motivates talking about
de-separation in the first place
um
and so this comes in the form of a
theorem that has two parts which i
described earlier but i'll remind you
so uh completeness
uh and soundness and
these are my terms for them and i'm not
totally sure how standard they are
but by completeness i mean if
something's not d separated
if x and y are not
d separated by z
then there's some distribution p that's
compatible with the graph in which
they're not conditionally independent
given z
and then there's soundness which
is the other direction which says any d
separations that you do see in the graph
are reflect uh
imply the corresponding conditional
independence
in any distribution compatible with that
graph
so
given
the amount of time i have i think i'm
going to
skip the proof of completeness and come
back to it later
and just focus on the soundness
which is more involved
but i think also maybe more interesting
so
okay so let's
look at the proof of soundness
so we're going to start by fixing
some conditioning set
z and sum x and y that are d separated
given z and we actually we don't really
need to fix x and y the important thing
is we fix our conditioning set
and we're going to transform our graph
via a series of operations into a new
graph in which
the conditional independence of x and y
given z
is manifestly evident
and then we're going to argue that any
distribution that was compatible with
our original graph is also compatible
with this new graph and so any
conditional independence in the new
graph
implies a conditional independence in
the latter graph in the original graph
and to do this we need a couple
definitions and some setup so first
uh we're going to order the vertices in
z
according to a topological order and
we're just going to introduce the
shorthand
z j is just the first j z vertices
and and we're going to
describe a procedure now for modifying
the graph
ah so first let me just introduce a
piece of terminology so we're gonna
this procedure is gonna have a step
where we complete a dag
and by this i just mean filling in all
the edges that are possible consistent
with some ordering of the dag so if i
have
x y
z
i complete this tag by just adding the x
to z
edge
if i have
x y
z i can complete it by either adding x
to z
or
z to x doesn't matter
um i'll just talk about completing or a
completion of a dag
without specifying with respect to what
topological order
uh it won't matter for our purposes
okay so
here's the sequence of graphs
uh so we're gonna start with the graph g
and then g zero
is just going to be g where we take all
the z vertices and we complete that sub
graph
and then
we're going to construct gj from gj
minus one
through the following steps
so first we're going to look at all the
ancestors
up so
gj is going to be constructed by doing
stuff with zj the j z vertex
so we're going to look at all the
ancestors in gj minus 1
of
zj and then we're going to remove the
other z vertices
but we're going to look at so this set
aj is all the ancestors and gj minus one
of our chosen z vertex
without all the other z vertices
and we're going to complete them
then we're going to flip all the edges
in this sub subgraph
and then we're going to complete
the sub graph aj and the other z
vertices
so this is
kind of complicated let's look at an
example
so let's say this is our initial graph
so the first step to get g zero would be
to add all the edges to complete the
subgraph on the z vertices
but uh here there are only two z
vertices and it already exists in edge
from z1 to z2 so that's trivial in this
case
you'll thank me that i only have two z
vertices in a second when you see what
the result of this looks like
g is equal to g zero here
now g1
so
uh
i've already
skipped i have lumped these steps
together but we take g0
we add an edge between
our we add edges to complete the sub
graph on all the ancestors of z1
so z1 starts off with ancestors a and b
and we added an edge between a and b and
we chose arbitrarily to add the edge
from b to a
and then we flipped all those edges
and then we would need to add edges from
all the uh
prior z vertices into the sub graph
since z1 is the first z vertex you don't
have to do anything
so now to get g2
we have to add a whole bunch more edges
so right if we look at what are the
ancestors of z2
in this graph well we have d
b and now we also have a we didn't have
this as an ancestor before but we do now
so we need to add edges from a to d
from b
uh so from a to d
from a to z2 from b to z2
i think that's everything and then we
need to flip it all around
and then we need to add edges from z one
to d
um
in the third step
so it becomes a crazy mess
um
anyway that's the result of doing this
process with only two z vertices you can
see why it's going to get incredibly
ugly with even more z vertices
um
so here's our claim about this
construction
which will
be useful
and basically
constitute the proof of the claim in an
uh it'll almost be all the way to
the desired claim
so
first
uh
the set zj so of the prefix of the z
vertices that we've
uh messed with by the time we finished
creating gj
is upwards closed
that is it contains all its ancestors
so why is this
well
we've uh
reversed all the edges
from
so inductively
if this is true for j minus 1 by the
time we get to j
j has
a bunch of ancestors that we wire up all
together and then we reverse all the
edges
from
ancestors of zj into zj
so
afterwards we have no edges into zj
right so if i look at this picture again
after the first step there are no edges
into z1 because we took all the edges
into z1 and flipped them around
after the second step
there are no edges into z 1 union z2
that is the only edge into z2 comes from
z1
because all the other edges into z2 we
flipped outward
so that's the
an informal proof of that proposition of
that
item
okay our next claim
after we've constructed gj
the ancestors of
zj
union
zj minus one
so in this case
that would be
for g1 that would be the ancestors of z1
union all the prior z vertices
after
g2 this is the ancestors
of z2
union all
the prior z vertices
there are no edges into this set
and this again follows inductively we've
gotten rid of all the edges into
z1
and our
all the edges into z1 in the previous
step
excluding other z vertices and now in
this step we get rid of all the edges
into
uh
ancestors
uh
from outside ancestors right so
if i look here
uh
first we observe the answer the set of
ancestors of z2
is upwards closed
right uh
excluding z1
and we've reversed all the edges
into
uh
we reversed all the edges
from
this ancestor set
so they're going to be not there are
going to be no edges into the set of
ancestors along with the z vertices
any edge into this ancestor set must
have come from
another z vertex earlier and so when we
look at the ancestors union other the
vertices
there are no incoming engines
so it turns out that in addition gj is
acyclic
um this is a little bit trickier to see
um and i'm not sure it's
worth going into detail um
so the next thing to observe is that
the set of ancestors
of zj along with the previous z vertices
is a complete directed subgraph
every edge that's possible is present
and that's because we first
add all the edges between ancestors
and then we add all the edges from the
previous z vertices
into
all the ancestors right so
inductively we're adding all the edges
that we can at each step of this
procedure
and here's the meaty step and the reason
that we're interested in this procedure
in the first place
if
or that we have an if and only if if fn
if x and y are deseparated by z in gj
then they're d separated
in the original graph so somehow doing
this operation preserves d separation
um
exactly with respect to z
right we're doing this operation with
respect to a particular choice of
conditioning set if we were to do it
with respect to a different choice
conditioning set then we wouldn't
preserve any or we would have no
guarantees on the d separations with
respect to this conditioning set
um and i'll prove this in a little more
detail
but then the final observation is that
our original distribution is compatible
with this distribution
or sorry with
gj the graph we're working with now
so if you buy all of these claims
then it will follow relatively
straightforwardly
that
um
any
well
let's take this for granted for the time
being and i'll show you how this implies
conclusion and then we'll go back and
prove what i think is the most
interesting part right
here um
so
let's say
so i want to show you that um
once we're done with this graph
or once we're done with this process and
we look at
g k the final graph
that the ancestors
of x
intersect
the ancestors of y
are contained within z
in this final graph
that is
they meet the hypoth or the
antecedent for this lemma from back in
the first session
um
along with
uh and moreover z is an ancestral set
that is
for an upwards closed set
so applying the lemma from the first
part
uh
this morning we can conclude that the
probability of
z
of x and y
given z
is equal to the probability of x
given z times the probability
of y given c
so
the fact that the ancestors of z
uh are sorry that z is upwards closed
this should be evident from the
construction we've always moved we in
each step
we
uh
take all the ancestors of z and we
reverse the edges so z no longer has
ancestors
except other z vertices so the set of z
vertices is upwards closed why is this
the case
why are the ancestors of x intersect
ancestors of y
uh going to be contained in c
um when x and y are d separated
originally
this is the hypothesis we need
we're assuming this we're going to show
that that implies
this
and then once we have this
along with this
uh the z is upwards closed which is
directly applied here
then we'll get the conditional
independence that we want
um
so why does this original deseparation
imply this fact
um
so assume for the sake of contradiction
um
that there existed
um
[Music]
x star
y star
in x and y respectively
such that um
some vertex a
not in z
was a common ancestor um
of x and y
expensive yes
so just the clarity of ancestors
yeah so in the original draft we could
have all sorts of crazy things going on
the point of this construction is to
kind of move all of our conditioning
variables to the top of the graph
so that we can easily decompose
the distribution over x and y given
these variables into something
well so that we can much more easily see
the conditional independence right um
yeah so
here uh this is all with respect to the
final graph
the only thing we're using from the
original graph is that we have this d
separation original
um
um
okay well so this is very
straightforward right all we have to do
is
observe that if there was some common
ancestor
that was not in the conditioning set
then
the following path
would be active in
the final graph
this would
prove that x and y are deconnected in
the final graph and if you believe
that this construction preserves
de-separation this is not possible
so
the meat of this result all comes from
showing that this construction preserves
the deseparation so i'm going to show
you that
any questions on the basic picture that
we're going for
okay
um
you use
this
okay
so why does this preserve
d
separation um
so let's assume that x and y are
deconnected
in uh
in g
and we'll show that they're deconnected
in gj
so first
by an inductive
or
we're proving this inductively so by the
inductive hypothesis they're deconnected
in g j minus one
so we just need to show that the
connection is preserved as we go from gj
minus one to gj
um
so let uh
t
j minus one be an active trail
between
uh
x prime
y prime
in gj minus one
we want to somehow find another active
trail in gj between these same vertices
uh that's
our current goal
so first observation is that this is
still a trail
in gj because when we go from gj minus
one to gj we just add edges
so every edge that we used in gj minus
one is still an edge in gj
um
and now
everything outside of the ancestors of
zj is not going to change
as we go from gj minus one to g
to gj right because all we're doing is
we're wiring up the ancestors together
flipping some edges and then
doing more stuff with this ancestor set
so we only have to worry about the parts
of
this trail that go through the ancestors
of zj
um
[Music]
so let's draw a picture so here's
kind of
the ancestors of z
j
and here i'm talking about in the graph
uh gj minus one
um
and
so we have some z vertices over here
we have some ancestors of zj without the
z vertices
um
so let's say tj minus one took an edge
into this set
touch some vertex and then left
this
these edges uh or this section of the
trail
doesn't
contain any edges between
vertices in the set so it's going to be
unaffected by doing any transformation
within this set
so the only thing we have to worry about
is
what if we have a segment of the trail
that really spends some time in this in
this set
is it going to remain active or is it
going to fall apart so we want to
restrict our attention to
active trails that actually go through
this set and we want to show that they
remain active or we can find some other
active trail to replace them with
in gj
so
let's
explicitly
look at such a trail
so um
[Music]
okay so let's look at uh
a segment of a trail of our trail tj
minus one
that uh consists of a bunch of vertices
in this ancestor set
so
and then let's pick a maximal length
segment
so if it goes through
here for five vertices and then leaves
and then comes back for another three
vertices
we want to look at the five vertex
segment and then also the three vertex
segment we're going to modify each of
those to get something that'll be an
active trail in gj
um
okay so the first observation is
if
let's give names to
this segment so if this is w
and this is u nu here does not mean
hidden variable it's just a name other
than x y or z
um
if this is w and this is u and these are
the end points of the segment that goes
to the ancestors
um
well the first thing to observe is there
are no edges entering this set
or sorry by this set i
mean this union
i'll call b
there are no edges in gj minus one
entering this set
because it's closed under ancestors
because the only ancestors of zj
are either here or here
so there are no edges entering the set
which means that we know that the trail
must
point out here
and i must point out here
yes
yeah so that can't happen because
uh there is no there are no incoming
edges into this set
um
right so
i can't enter here
and then leave the set with an edge
in this direction because
this vertex would also be in the center
um
[Music]
okay
so
uh another observation is since this
original trail was active
and neither w nor u is a collider
because they both have outgoing edges in
the trail
neither w nor u could have been in
z our conditioning set
and now
in
gj
right we've added edges between all the
ancestors
um
and in particular we've completed this
entire subgraph
which means that in gj there is an edge
either from w to u or from u to w
and so we can take the trail in gj minus
one and just
replace this entire segment that went
through these ancestors
with just
a single edge from wtu
and the claim is because neither w nor u
was in the conditioning set itself
and
the edges
uh
from w to the prior vertex and from u to
the next vertex
are outgoing
uh neither of
neither w nor u will be a collider
in the resulting trail in gj
and so the resulting trail will be
active
even as we replace all of these vertices
with this
right so if we had an active trail
in gj minus one we end up with an active
trail in gj
a much shorter active trail because
we've just taken a shortcut through all
the ancestors
so what about the other direction how do
we know we haven't accidentally
introduced a bunch more active trails
and that
d sub uh
and the d separations
in
gj
sorry and gj minus one
are not preserved in gj right so all
we've shown so far is that d connections
are preserved but we also want to show
the d separations at the preserve
um
okay
so
how do we do that
it's kind of going to be the same
argument in reverse so let tj now
be an active trail in gj
and let it be a minimal active trail
um that is we can't
uh replace it with any subsequent we
can't
find another active trail
with any using any subsequence of the
vertices in this trail
um
so by the argument immediately
proceeding right
if it's minimal active trail in gj
then it can't visit more than
two vertices in this entire segment at a
time
because if it did we could find a
shortcut
by the the argument before whenever we
visit three or more vertices
uh
we can just take the single edge between
the start and end vertex of that segment
and that'll be that'll remain inactive
and will preserve the activeness of the
trail
and
moreover um
uh
well
yeah and in particular
we end up with um
we know that
in
gj any active trail must
have uh
any time it visits this set it must do
so
with a segment that looks like
like this basically uh so we have some
undirected edge and then between two
vertices in this section and then we
have an outgoing edge
to
uh something not in this set
and so we want to take this trail in gj
and figure out another active trail in
gj minus one
that uh corresponds to it somehow
and so what we're gonna do is just
replace this shortcut
with
the full sequence of vertices needed
to get from w to u
in gj minus one
so
remember w and u are both
ancestors of zj in gj minus one
which means that in gj minus one there's
some directed path
to zj
uh from w and there's some directed path
from
u to z j
and so we're gonna take our trail
which
uh
[Music]
which
had to look like this
in the section where it was in this set
and we're going to expand out the single
edge into
two directed paths one down from w to zj
and the other down from u to z j
at which point we now have
a collider
and we condition on zj and so that'll be
active
so
i'm this is
not totally sufficient because it might
not be the case that w and u are
independent in the sense that
the path from w to zj
might actually go through you
right or the path from u to zj might go
through w
if
w and u are both ancestors of zj
via the same path
so if
it was the case that w
at a directed path
uh
i don't know if that's two
well
do you
and then
i'm just gonna
move slightly
to zj
sorry this is a u
then
this construction wouldn't work
right but instead
what we could do is take the w to u path
in our original graph or sorry take the
w to u path
directly and then we have a directed
path
and that's still an active segment
right so
i don't want to go into much more detail
on this though everything's spelled out
in the handout but the punch line is we
can expand the single edge
into
a path in gj minus one that will remain
active because we know that w and u are
both ancestors
of something
in the conditioning set
or because the path that we take between
w and u is just a directed path and then
we don't have to worry about the
conditioning set at all
um
that's about all
uh okay and so
once we've established this
that we preserve d separation in this
construction then
along with the fact that
in this final graph
z is uh upwards closed set and if x and
y were d separated given z
then
all the common ancestors of x and y are
inside z
we get the conclusion that if x and y
were d separated in our original graph
they are conditionally independent
in our distribution
uh sorry in any distribution compatible
with uh this new graph
and
i claim that our original distribution
is compatible with this new graph
so why is that
right so i've taken our original graph
and i've modified it wildly
um
so here's the original graph
why do i know that
after
changing it to this
a distribution that was compatible with
the original graph is still compatible
with this
and the reason is the following
in each step
i'm building a complete sub graph on
some
z vertex and its ancestors
and a complete sub graph is consistent
with every distribution
because i can just
factor any distribution according to a
complete sub graph
by
just applying the chain rule
and so as long as i'm making
modifications that add edges
and
to a complete subgraph
i'm guaranteed to be fine
right i can't inadvertently
introduce a conditional independence in
this
sequence of operations that wasn't
present in the original graph because i
add all the edges i can
and then even if i reverse all the edges
within this set
that doesn't change anything i still
have a complete sub graph so all the
distribution so it's consistent with all
distributions on that segment
and uh
yeah the conclusion basically follows
from that
so i've
and it's kind of interesting to realize
that
i've shown that
x and y are independent given z
in my original graph i've also shown the
much stronger thing that they're
independent in
a graph you get by applying this
procedure one of the steps of which is
just hooking together all the ancestors
of every conditioned variable
so somehow doing this procedure
is fine like as long as you condition on
some variable you can
kind of
take all of its ancestors and wire them
together and if you were still if you
were d
separated originally you won't somehow
connect variables
um
anyway
that's about all i wanted to say about
this uh
proof
um
the details are all in the handout
um
okay
so
i'm afraid yeah i definitely do not have
time to do the other direction of this
proof
um so i'll move on to the do calculus
um but please do take a look at the
other direction i think it's quite nice
okay so
as i mentioned way back in the beginning
the do calculus is a series of
rules for manipulating interventional
distributions so
let me remind you of the
picture we had the beginning so
we
have some distribution with or some
graph that corresponds to a causal model
that we can factor
our distribution according to the graph
but the graph might have unobserved
variables
and we want to write an interventional
distribution in terms of
purely observable quantities so here's
the correct expression for
unless i've made another mistake uh for
the interventional distribution
uh
sorry this is
the
ignore that derivation
because it is incorrect
i
this is the derivation for the example
with a mediating z variable so this just
syntactically doesn't make any sense
here sorry about that
so ignoring this line
uh the only takeaway from this slide is
we're gonna introduce some new notation
um
the following notation so we'll write do
x
as uh
to mean the intervention in which we've
set the variable x to the assignment
little x
and we'll use this funny kind of
do
uh
notation to the right of a conditioning
bar
in place of this
p sub x
uh notation
and
as i mentioned before intervening on x
so
if i started with this graph
the graph i'd get after intervening on x
is the following
is this graph
right so the
graph
change that's induced by an intervention
is removing all the parents of
sorry removing all edges from parents of
intervention variables to those
intervention variables
and we'll write g sub x with this bar on
top of it
to denote this graph
so
in this notation the do operation
takes our original graph and replaces it
with
uh
the graph where we've cut all the parent
edges to x um
yeah
okay so
again the do calculus is a set of rules
for manipulating interventional
distributions
um
so one observation is
if our original distribution is
compatible with g
then the interventional distribution is
going to be compatible with
uh
g bar x
i don't have a great name for that but
uh
and so we can use d separation to reason
about interventional distribution so we
can take conditional independencies that
are implied by d separation
and use that to manipulate
interventional distributions
so
let's talk about
uh
so the do calculus consists of three
rules
um the first of which is way simpler
than the others uh
so the first of which
characterizes when
you can remove an observation
from uh
an inter or from a
probability expression without changing
anything so
let's say i'm intervening on x and i'm
observing z and w and i want to see that
the effect that has on what the
distribution on y the results is
this says that i can drop the
observation of z
so long as
y and z are d separated
by x and w in
the post-intervention graph
um
so let me just prove this
quickly
so
this actually is very straightforward
so
if
y and z
are
d separated by x and w in the
post-intervention graph then
by the soundness of d separation
we immediately conclude that y and z
are
conditionally independent given x and w
in the distribution resulting in the
interventional distribution because this
interventional distribution is
compatible with
this
graph post surgery
so i'm directly using the uh
soundness of d separation to conclude
things
or to
uh conclude that i can just drop this z
from
this expression
so let me draw an example to illustrate
what this might look like
so let's say i have x here
y here
and
v here
and uh
example um
sorry i don't have a great example off
the top of my head
um
risk coming up with a non-example so i
will
move on from that and hopefully uh come
back with examples later
um let me
get to
a more interesting uh rule
so
this
second rule
lets us
uh
for characterizes when we can
replace
uh
interventions with observations without
changing the result
um and before i
prove this rule i need to introduce one
tool that will be useful in the proof of
this rule and third rule
which is the augmented graph
and so the augmented graph which i'll
denote
[Music]
g and some set z
is the graph i get
by taking
my original graph
i'll just draw an abstract picture for
it
and i look at
some subset of the vertices z
and i add new vertices
um
so 5 z1
and
i add a new vertex
z1 hat
zn hat
and
it's to be interpreted as follows so
sorry the augmented graph
corresponds to an augmented causal model
the i'll describe the augmented causal
model which will have a graph
an induced graph which is obtained by
just adding
z vertices as follows so the augmented
causal model
is the following
um
for each vertex
in
let's see
so
if my original model had u
v
f
some distribution over u
um
my new model is going to have as vertex
set v
union
z hat
where z hat is just
a set of additional v vertices
z i hat for each
vertex in
z
[Music]
and
um
my functions f that determine each of
the variables
will be unchanged except for
the functions corresponding to the z
vertices
so
f of z i in this modified
model
will be replaced with
some g of z i
as follows
um
[Music]
so
g of z i will take uh
all the inputs that f
did um
so
i'll
write this as uh
parents so okay let's call this original
model
m
it'll be the parents in m
of z i
plus it will have one new parent which
is
z i hat
and it will do the following
so uh
zi hat
will have domain
equal to
the domain of z i
with one additional value
which is
we'll write epsilon
and the
idea behind this is we're going to use
zi hat to control whether or not we're
intervening
on zi
so
the value
here of g of zi will be
just f of zi
if um
zi hat is equal to epsilon
so if
this additional variable
which just is some new input attached
just to
if z hat one
is set to epsilon then z one does
whatever it did before
and if z
hat
i
is not set to epsilon
then zi just adopts the value
of z hat so uh
so
what is the augmented graph
with respect to so if i have an original
causal model
and i augment with respect
to z
by introducing these additional
variables
that
capture whether or not we're intervening
on z
the augmented graph is going to be
the graph g with the addition of
new vertices z hat
and edges from the z hat vertices to the
z vertices
and so why introduce this complicated
different
[Music]
version of
an intervention uh
why
introduce these augmented models and
then their corresponding graphs
the reason is that uh
we now can transform
statements about uh
about observations and interventions in
the original model into
we can now express the due calculus in
terms of conditional independence's
independencies in these augmented models
so
um
as follows so
first
claim
which i'll use this other board for
um
um
so i can express
in the
in the original uh
puzzle model the distribution on y given
x or
i now have this equality i can express
the original distribution of y given x
as
the new distribution of y given
that this intervention variable is set
to epsilon that is we're not intervening
and we observe
x equal x
so
uh
um
and i can also express
the um
or the
interventional
distribution
as follows
as a conditional probability with
respect to this augmented
uh
model and augmented graph
right so the probability of
the distribution on y given do x is the
same thing as the distribution on y
given that i've set
these intervention variables to the
value x
and
now if i can show the conditional
independence
of
some quantity
with respect to these intervention
variables
that is if i can show that i have some
uh
y given
if i can show that this expression is
equal
to
[Music]
this
expression that is
these two uh that because of conditional
independence the value of
this intervention variable is irrelevant
to computing the probability of y
i've shown that whether or not i
intervene
makes no difference
to
the distribution that i obtain
so
i realized that was a complicated
definition and i'm not sure
uh
how clear that was
does do you have questions or should i
proceed
for this construction you could assume
um while you guarantee this positivity
when you draw the new edge but in the
previous section we're doing
modifications on the graph it doesn't
introduce
essentially additional constraints
um
so
the previous the procedure of the graph
modification procedure
uh that i was going through earlier is
just a tool of proof to establish the
soundness of de-separation
so
uh
and that entire proof is not in that
possible possibilities oh uh
is it really
it's normally exposed to
it does not
i'm not sure i'd have to think about it
a bit more but uh
d separation being sound
i think should not depend on
positivity uh
over the proof potentially without
assumption
let me get back to you on that i haven't
thought about that particularly
yes so uh
one thing
that i totally haven't gotten yet is
with this second rule
we changed um
a conditioned
do said into just a zed but one thing
i'm not totally clear on
is that uh
like i thought
the definition of
like i i think i'm not getting the do
operator because
probability of y given do little x i
thought was shorthand for
probability of y given
capital x equal to little x
but it seems that there's a difference
between these two things
for me yeah so the do operator is
the interventional distribution so
this is we take our original model we
replace the mechanism that computes x as
a function of whatever and we just set
it to some constant value
which is different from observing x
because when we observe x that
has implications for
other variables in particular by using
bayes rule of looking backwards right
you can figure out
that implies things about the
predecessor's effects
in the intervention nothing is implied
about predecessors because we have no
predecessors anymore
great thank you mom
so this augmentation procedure or this
augmentation uh
of models and then
the
corresponding graphs is a way of
relating
um
interventional distributions and up and
distributions without interventions that
doesn't involve doing this graph surgery
we add this extra variable that kind of
we we set to different values to
uh
decide whether we're intervening or not
and then if we can show that some
expression is conditionally independent
of an intervention
variable that's the same thing as saying
the expression doesn't depend on whether
or not
uh we intervene
um
so
that's the setup
and we now have enough that i can
restate rule two and uh
i think we have enough time to prove the
equivalence between the interventional
formula the formulation with these
additional interventional variables and
the formulation without and
uh
the rule will be
a straightforward consequence of the
version with these interventional
variables um so could we bring those
slides back up
um
oh yes
sorry uh
what
so
is that
at least visible if not yeah it is
visible wow
okay
so
the way these new interventional
variables uh
these new augmented variables work
is that
they
take on values from
let me
so
let's do a simple example um
so
i have
uh
x y
u
so if i wanted to augment with respect
to x here what i do is i add
a new variable which i'll call x hat
and i replaced the equation that
determined x as a function of u with a
new equation which i'll call g instead
of f
just
so g
will
take as arguments the value now of
so previously x was determined by u
now g will be determined by
u and x hat
and
it will
if x hat is set to something other than
epsilon
g will just ignore the value of u
and just copy x hat
if it's set to epsilon then
g will
uh
do what it would have done before so if
our original function was f of u
then
it will
just do what f did
so observing the event
x hat equals x
is equivalent to intervening and setting
x
to x
uh
yeah so we now have a distribution over
a larger set of variables that different
settings of this one variable
switch us between the
interventional distribution on our
original set and the
non-intervened distribution
um so it's like it's a formal device
that
lets us
that now and now we can reason about
de-separation is modified graph and that
will have implications for
the equivalence of interventional and
observational distributions in
the resulting graph um
okay
yeah i think this is a good time to
break and we'll come back and prove
rule 2 and rule 3
and talk about the id algorithm after a
break
thank you
we'll reconvene at 3 30 coffee is
outside and i think maybe some snacks as
well
okay